i'd like to share with you one of the
best remedies for a uti a urinary tract
infection
let's first cover the symptoms
burning upon urination
frequent urination the urge to urinate
when your bladder is empty and also you
might have abdominal pain which is a
little lower in your abdomen lower back
pain
blood in the urine cloudy urine or your
urine has a bad odor now as far as the
microbe involved 80 of the time it's e
coli
utis are five times more common in women
than men and that has to do with the
location of where your urethra is to the
anal area and so as far as anatomy goes
you have the two kidneys right here
which connect to these two little tubes
right here they're called uratures and
these tubes drain down into the bladder
and then you have an additional tube
called the urethra when you have a
urinary tract infection you can have an
infection here here
here or right in there but the e coli
tend to want to survive so they're going
to form biofilms in the bladder which is
going to make it very difficult to
attack because now they go underneath
the radar and this is why
a lot of people especially women get
recurrent utis over and over and over
especially the more antibiotics they
take because these microbes now become
resistant which basically means they
morph and they get smarter and they're
harder to kill and these antibiotics
don't work anymore so the more
antibiotics you take
the worse things get so this is why
you're watching this video to try
something more natural and one way to
diagnose the uti is a simple urine test
and you're looking for there's high
amounts of nitrates and leukocytes which
are white blood cells there's also other
tests that you can do to confirm it now
when people think uti they automatically
go to cranberry juice
and cranberry supplements
that's been somewhat effective but not
very effective because the cranberry
tends to make the bacteria slide off and
not stick to the inside of the bladder
wall so
cranberry in general i think is good for
a preventative thing and i'm talking
about maybe cranberry pills not the
juice because there is some sugar in
there but typically once you have a uti
cranberry juice doesn't really work that
well okay so what i'm going to recommend
is something that does work a lot better
it's a combination of oregano oil
capsules as well as thyme capsules okay
now both of these are
pretty potent
herbal natural antibiotics specifically
with this natural chemical in both of
these plants called carvacrol and when
you get the oregano make sure it's at
least 60 percent
carvacrol
and i would recommend taking at least
200 milligrams at least it could be more
four times
per day of oregano oil and as far as
time
try to find something that's 500
milligrams and you can take that once a
day
because this chemical in both of these
plants inhibits
biofilms it also kills e coli the major
microbe that's involved in this
infection
i'm also going to recommend taking apple
cider vinegar two tablespoons and 16
ounces of water
to drop your ph to make your ph more
acidic if you're more acidic there'll be
less pathogenic microbes the acid tends
to inhibit the formation of these
microbes the other thing i'm going to
recommend is to drink at least 2.5
liters of fluid a day and of course you
can add that apple cider vinegar to this
liquid because the more fluid you have
you can actually assist and help
fleshing out these microbes as you're
killing them with these two things right
here there's also an optional step i
would recommend okay
taking some natural diuretic
that way you can help to increase the
flow of urine through these
these channels through here asparagus is
a really good natural
diuretic dandelion greens is another
good natural
diuretic or potassium citrate
as in a lot of electrolytes okay so that
will help flush things out very nicely
now since we're on the topic of natural
antibiotics okay and oregano oil there's
some additional information i think
you'd be very interested in i put it up
right here check it out